hey everybody is Jessie and welcome to
live coding with Jessie today we're
gonna continue on with what we were
doing yesterday which was making a
homepage using material design so we got
our our buttons sorted out yesterday I
think we got our bunch sorted out I just
looked at it on my other screen here and
they don't look right anymore
he'll be on all right I'm on a different
branch alright so I have my node member
hat on today so you kind of see the node
member on there so it's cold and today
we get to dress down and my coworkers
are trying to peek in on the last string
we got to dress down today so I got to
wear normally I have to wear dress
clothes but I got to wear jeans my
November hoodie so I haven't gotten to
show off any of this gear on the stream
so I figured I would today rights
all right so let's get started
I let me switch to y'all can see the
screen okay so yesterday we got these
buttons in here and they will keep this
configuration no matter what the screen
sizes and their narrow enough that they
will fit on small screens even on the
narrowest of phones the only thing I was
thinking of with this and I'm not
worrying about it right now cuz we're
just gonna try to lay out a potential
you know homepage to show my boss
we might actually they have more than
one will just I will probably just do it
on different branches but I'm thinking
maybe on a larger screen these buttons
could be larger and then we'll use some
media queries to scale them down on
small screens we also put in this events
section within this card and right now
you know it's really basic I think this
is enough just to kind of get the
concept that we could put a list here it
could be events it could be news
whatever we wanted to put there now I'd
like to fill in this using kind of like
a masonry grid style and just throw in
some different types of content just
maybe some stock photos some areas for
text some areas for video just so we
have a nice visual what could happen
with this homepage and I don't think
we'll get this done today but if we do
get that done today then maybe we'll
move on and I'd like to do maybe a more
traditional homepage that would be kind
of linear and tell a story so you know
would you'd still the hope here a
section would be the same but then you
may have just some full width sections
that would explain what's so great about
Franciscan University why would you want
to come
and finish up with another
call-to-action at the bottom I think
those will be two good points to start
from and then I think we can get some
feedback and you know we rework it
we'll probably come back to this page
several times over the next month or so
and work on some interior pages as well
but we'll go through a couple cycles of
you know trying some stuff out getting
feedback and then making some
adjustments getting more feedback so
enough talk let's start out this
Pomodoro timer and I started doing some
code now if you're not familiar with
Pomodoro timer this is a way to break up
your work and I like to use it when I'm
working throughout the day but it's also
nice on the stream because it reminds me
to quit coding and check out the live
chat and answer any questions that there
may be in there so that's what I'm gonna
do if you ask a question in the live
chat during the 25 minute session please
be patient and I will get to your
question whenever the 25 minute period
is over we'll do a break answer some
questions do another 25 minute session
so I'm hoping to do two coding sessions
today let's start the first one
all right so yep this is our our code
and right now we're using react and
we're using next js' to kind of scaffold
out our react app next j/s offers a
server-side rendering without very much
work on our part and then it offers us a
routing system built in so anything in
this pages folder will become its own
route so the home page is indexed j/s
but then the other pages are just you
know what their names are here so we
have we have a page called page we have
a page called faculty all right so we're
going to be working on just on the home
page today so we're gonna scroll down
normally you wouldn't want to
hard-code things in your component like
this this end is going to end up being a
really big component once we're done
with it but then what we'll do is once
we're set on a design we'll go back and
we'll actually break these down into
other components and have it populated
with data you know from an a database
we'll pull it in with a graph QL API and
then that way these will get a lot
smaller
we won't clutter them up with you know
with a lot of you know text content
right here in the component okay so I'd
like to add let's see I think I'd like
to break up this section here and two
maybe two cars let's see how this looks
breaking this up into two cards I don't
want it to be too too small but at least
on a large screen I think I would it
would be okay to have it like that so
let's try that first
see
all right so here's that first card and
just has an image at the top so what
we'll do is we'll just copy this now
we're using material UI for a lot of our
components because it uses that Google's
material design if you're not familiar
with react just think about using the
bootstrap for a regular site material UI
plays the same role for a react app as
bootstrap plays for just a normal you
know HTML site but in in this case it's
following material design and this we
need to make this alright that's good
and then let's change these values so
instead of we have a 12 column grid so
if you give it a value of 12 that means
it's full width if you give it a value
of 6 that means it takes a path the
width of the screen so we want it to
take up 1/4 so we're gonna put in 3 so
that each one of these takes up only 3
columns let's say that see what we get
alright great so now we've lit this up
into two cards on let's see what screen
size we can get I'm gonna shrink this
down just to get a more realistic screen
size the screen that I have on right now
that you can see is is pretty large 20
it's over 20 inches I don't remember how
how much over 20 inches it is and it's
also a 2k screen so it's not not
everybody's gonna have a screen like
this ok not bad I think we can
definitely fit some content in here and
it won't look you know too small
let's see so I just checking out the
live chat a bit hey everybody
alright so let's throw in some text
content in here and I don't have to
think about what I want to put in here
so let's remove this media and you know
let's remove this card actions so I
think what happen is when we originally
put this in here
I think the card content would have been
the proper thing to use but it was
overlaying over top of the image or
something was happening so that's why we
ended up born with this card actions
normally you would actually have you
know clickable actions in here so let's
get rid of some of this yeah this just
get rid of that and let's put in I
believe it's card Connie has card
content so if you're not familiar with
what's going on here these components
that we're using they don't come
built-in with react these come from the
material UI component library so we have
to bring in material which we just added
it through node package manager and
we've import these components up the top
you see we're bringing in these
components for material UI and
and I am using Visual Studio code as my
editor if you've seen in previous videos
you know that I I've used atom before so
I'm still getting used to what I have
here I was expecting a auto-complete for
this for this tag I thought it would
make the closing tag automatically but
it didn't so to check my settings but a
bit of the card content and then we'll
want to do a typography typography tag
and let's go with type and give it a
type of let's give it a type of h3 just
see what size it is
and let's just say it's a 99% graduates
I was super awesome alright so that is
definitely going to draw students in
let's see how that looks
wow that's really small I can't believe
h3 is that small maybe that's not even a
real type
I guess we'll try an h2 and see I hate
to use age tags
unless they're actually headings hmm
all right something's wrong let's look
up typography in the material UI
documentation may be under style yep
typography okay if you want to follow
along and check out the documentation be
sure to get the documentation for the
latest version so for the beta version
so the URL is material - UI - next calm
- okay
check out the API hmm
okay you can't put an H you could put in
display that's weird
for some reason I thought you could put
in a stag's maybe my memory is just
terrible or maybe this changed at some
point all right well now we definitely
need to switch things up a bit so let's
see what we want
let's try display two
there we go all right not bad just to
show and we're gonna have to be
hmm
here's where we're gonna have to be
careful and we'll be able to see it when
I add some more cards in but I want to
make sure that these gaps get filled in
so we wouldn't have the next row all
starting here and then a big gap here
and I also don't want this card just to
fill up the space and have a lot of
white space here so let's see what
happens when we do this with this
current grid system we're using if we
don't get what we want we're gonna have
to try something different but I do have
some ideas so I think I have at least
two ideas one of them I know has worked
for me before on previous sites so we'll
try them up okay and I know that I see
there's some questions in the live chat
I'm gonna go over all the questions in
about 13 minutes so whenever this timer
is is done I'm gonna get all the
questions so just please be patient and
I'll do my best to answer everything all
right so let's just add in some more
cards I really want to see how these
stack and the easiest way to do this is
just going to be to throw in some more
items so first thing I'm going to try to
do is still like this within the same
container I'm not sure exactly if this
will work or novelist's try it out
okay so doing it this way you see we
have the problem that I thought we would
have let's go to the documentation and
see if there's already a built-in way to
solve this
okay I'm sorry I just glanced there
michael says can't follow along as usual
at the hospital getting my bi-weekly
phlebotomy for a blood issue I hope
everything's okay with your your health
issues Michael so I didn't realize that
you had that so I hope it's not really
serious always like talking with you
here on the live chat so anyway if doing
the stream at this time conflicts
regularly with your appointments let me
know and maybe eggs try to do it a
different time because I'd hate for you
to have to miss okay where we at
grid area
okay so we're we're checking out the
grid here online content interface
between his face around
the foolish
well alright let's check out the demos
I don't not worry about that
all right I don't think there's anything
covering that
stretch centers my staff listens
I'm a maybe align content or align items
would work but I don't know I'm I'm a
little skeptical that this would do
anything all right so I'm gonna go to my
next options right so I have two ideas
one idea we've used before previous
projects and that's to bring in masonry
layout package that'll handle all this
for us and we'll position things using
javascript I'd rather not do that if we
don't have to but we might have to my
other idea and we saw this yesterday
briefly it just kind of caught my eye so
I thought why not try is to use or is it
I don't remember what it was called so
I'm I have to go through this list
it was a great list you know what I
don't want to go through the API I want
the demos component demos
I think this was it I think it was the
grid list
let me see if this is actually giving us
what we want you know it's so far I'm
just seeing I'm seeing everything in the
same height in each row so the still
isn't really solving the issue
so let me check
and check the source
okay there they're mapping over this
[Music]
all right so I'm going to
I'm gonna adjust the height okay yeah
this is pretty much what I thought
let's adjust see if there's anything
happens
yeah so this isn't gonna help us either
we still have these gaps okay I don't
think there's anything built-in to
material UI I'm going to go through this
list quickly just to see if there's
something that maybe I'm missing here
yeah I'm I'm not seeing anything okay so
we're still gonna be able to use the
grid the grid elements most likely but
we're gonna add in package it's going to
use a little bit of JavaScript to
position each one of these cards and the
position will update if the screen width
changes and that way we're always going
to have we're going to make use of all
our space we're not gonna have these big
gaps trying to think where did we use
this we did use this on on the project
actually let me let me see if it bullets
I don't know if I actually made this
site now I didn't I think I just have
the site locally I don't I don't have a
live version of it but we did this on
the bulletin site so that'll probably be
the best thing to look at to figure out
how we're gonna do this so let's check
out github and I'll make my font size a
bit bigger wow I just got a bunch of
emails my work email alright it looks
like nothing is important here we go
bulletin react so I'm going to that FUS
mark home bulletin react repository and
let's check out a source and it's our
views
probably homework it's been a while
since I've looked at this repo grid
renderer okay so you got to find rid
renderer
cojones
there we go let's open up grid view and
list our grid render and grid view to
try to see what's going on and let's see
okay
all right I see it looks like what we
had done here was we imported some CSS
from another library so not material UI
I think we imported some of the :
classes from materialized CSS which is
basically just like bootstrap accepted
as material design styles so I'd rather
not import this if we don't have to
certainly not gonna import the whole
thing I mean I maybe would pull little
pieces of it if we need it but it seems
like yeah this is something we could
definitely do alright and let me check
this one out as well
grid renderer okay this is just
switching us between the different views
so we have in this particular project we
had a toggle well actually is more than
at all you could you could toggle grid
view or list view but then you could
also go to a print view if you wanted to
it's not going to be that complicated
for us we're gonna have one view I mean
we could certainly have more than one if
we wanted but let's just start off with
one okay I'm gonna pull this over onto
my other screen to make it easier for me
to reference it and then let's pull up
our code on this screen and let's make
sure let's double check that this repo
that we are using is up-to-date react
react nation tree component check to
make sure it's up to date they haven't
had any braking changes or anything that
we need to be aware of so we can go to
the releases and see their last release
was up
20 second let me think I think that we
we worked on this project the bulletin
project around or after that time so
there shouldn't be changes we could
always verify by looking at the
package.json and our project so we'll
bring back that repo here check out the
package.json and see react nation
component six-point 0.1 yeah so we'll
have the same versions which is good so
we won't we should be able to do this
the same way and a reward and yep that
makes me components all right so my
timer is about up I'd say the last thing
we could do is yarn add react masonry
components and we'll let that install
while I go back to the live chat I'm
going to take a short break and scroll
up and try to answer all your questions
all right Dimitri yes where I got the
the grid where I import the grid from
its hero UI so let's check that out
where you import so I had to do like an
NPM install of material UI so I have
already done it so I'm not going to do
it again but you if you're using NPM I
think what would be NPM it's it install
save so how you do it it's been so long
since I just used NPM but co UI or what
I usually do is I use yarn so I do the
yarn add material UI that will bring
that into your project and then you can
do the imports and you can use material
UI so check out the material UI github
repo or their website and it'll walk you
through how to import that into your
project and use it and this is for react
only that you want to use those
components so if you're not doing a
react project that's this is not what
you want to use if you'd like to use
material design and a non react project
try out materialized CSS and I think
that's I think it's materialized calm
and mature as a materialized CSS calm
it's worth looking up
yeah materialized CSS calm that's what
you want to use for you know like a non
reacts ight you know plain HTML site
it's basically any site that you
normally want to use bootstrap for you
can replace bootstrap with materialise
and it'll give you the same stuff just
in material design style
Patrick's is one percent of graduates
are super lame yeah I didn't really
think that one through but I guess that
that's they could just be regular
awesome they don't have to be lame so
it's 99% of graduates are super awesome
and yeah let's change that up right now
because I could see that could be
problematic
how's that see then there's no negative
connotation everybody's some type of
awesome the hopeless Brit says might be
a silly question but do web developers
working in offices have an open mind
about people who think out loud when
programming
I guess it shouldn't matter if people
have earphones in I actually can hear it
so I have my own office so I don't have
other people working right next to me so
it's not really a problem but I can hear
the person in the office next to me I
can hear them on the other side of my
wall talking sometimes but only if I
don't have my headphones on so you're
right I wear headphones all the time
when I'm working I always have music
going so noise doesn't bother me if I
happen to not have headphones on for
some reason I can hear noise it's
usually not a problem for me there's a
classroom right on this side of my
office and I can hear the professor's
lecturing in their classroom depending
on who the professor is I can hear them
and that can be somewhat distracting if
I don't have my headphones on but I
would say I mean if if you're the type
of person that needs to talk things out
out loud then if you can at all like
stay away from the other people you know
get a little bit farther away from that
probably best just to be respectful I
guess you can't make them wear
headphones so huh I don't know how I'd
handle that luckily I don't have to deal
with that I'm not sure how I would
handle that one yeah it doesn't bother
me personally because I can always wear
the headphones
I'm gonna go back to the coding here in
just a second
I wanted to make sure I made a note of
where I'm leaving off 19 okay so the
last comment that I got to a live chat
is from a beam of sis I don't know how
but I'm in love with material design all
right well this is this is the stream
for you because we material design
everything here all right so the rest of
the questions I'm going to get to after
this next coding session if you can't
stick around to hear the answer then
check out the recording of this stream
later on when you have a chance and I'll
answer all the questions towards the end
of the the stream
all right what were you doing okay I
just installed the masonry layout great
so let's bring in masonry and like I
mentioned at the beginning the stream
but I think it's worth mentioning again
I wouldn't keep this component as it is
now in this state I would definitely
refactor this and remove as much of this
as I could into separate components so
just for now when we're messing around I
don't think it's worth it to make all
these different components because we
may not even keep half of them you know
for the finished product but eventually
this will need to be refactored
it would just be a mess to come in here
and try to figure out what's going on if
we left it like this also we are going
to be able to reuse a lot of these
components and other places in the site
so right we can't reuse them if they
only exist in here all right so we got
masonry in here now now let's try to do
something with it so let's wrap that was
a really hard piece out I just made
those weird
let's wrap our components in this
masonry hmm let's see what happens if I
change this grid to masonry
I'm not really expecting this to work
but if it does it'll be pretty awesome
and quick so it's always worth a shot
then I wrap the wrong thing in here I
did all right let's try it again
I didn't mean to wrap that part and it
this is what I wanted to wrap in in
masonry and I need to get rid of
container and all the way down here
Mason
all right well that's something right
let's see probably let's see
i flex
Thanks
I think our we're gonna we're not going
to be able to use grid okay just rook
just says in the live chat that for the
new newest versions of NPM you don't
need to use the save flag anymore you
can just NPM I and then the package name
alright cool that's that's a lot shorter
so I mean I mentioned earlier a much
longer way to do it it's unnecessary so
you could just do NPM I and then with
your UI or whatever package you have
thanks for that rook I'm behind the
times on on NPM that is much easier all
right so let's change these let's change
all this grid stuff because the the CSS
that's going along with all this these
grid components is conflicting with what
we're trying to do in masonry so let's
for now just change these all to divs
all right so they're all going to be
divs I don't think it's going to work
we're gonna have to add some other
classes to that all right let's
all right so for everything where we
have the three let's just say hmm now I
understand why we added in the
materialized classes last time I'd hoped
we wouldn't need to do that but we
probably will so let's go with style
with 25% we have a 25% with for that one
and then for the ones that are six
oh why don't we have another six yeah
three three six we should have another
six do we not add another one I guess we
didn't okay so only have one that's
small six and for this one we're going
to change it to be 50% we're not going
to keep things like this this is just to
test it out if this works we'll change
these into classes so just to test we're
kind of making our own little grid
system here our little column system I
said probably won't stay like this once
mmm let me see what the styles aren't
here
I gotta be missing something
okay
I'm checking out how we implemented this
in the previous project just to see if
I'm missing something
hmm
I think we're missing anything let's see
we had our masonry layout up didn't we
their react nation tree component let's
take a look at their documentation
just look at that basic usage mystery
options
you
let me check I think we're using the
Maestri component right I think the
problem is our containers
this a little bit better let's try this
so we we had a display flex on our hero
cards which this is not really a great
name for these now at one time they were
gonna peak up into the hero section
let's try to use this without display
there we go
all right better much better there we go
okay all right so you can see how this
is supposed to work obviously we need to
set our our gutter right our space
between which we haven't done but aside
from the awkwardness of that you can see
we're not wasting space right if we had
more cards you would see it would really
not be wasting a lot of space we we
didn't add in anything for smaller
strains but this would of course
everything would go full width and for a
smaller screen but this is what I wanted
this kind of fluid grid system that
automatically adjusts it doesn't take up
space all right
not bad would rather not have have to do
this in a totally different way let me
think
just wondering if I could read implement
our grid and just adjust the CSS for the
container and if that would work
I think it's worth a shot it's not like
I did that much work that it would be
hard to to get it back so I'm just gonna
hit the back button a bit bring our grid
back and then take these out see what
happens
okay not not super terrible actually so
if we can just figure out what's making
this so thin we might be able to
continue to use our grid which is nice
that means we don't have to come up with
our own our own system our own column
system or we don't have to import it
from materialize all right so let's
check out this is the container div and
I can bring dev tools over for this so
we're checking out that container div
that definitely needs to be bigger or
else you all can't see it let's switch
this around a bit to move this over and
stretch this out there we go alright so
this is a container you can see it's
getting this position:absolute the exact
positioning from the JavaScript which is
what we wanted let's see I'm gonna go
through
so removing that doesn't really do
anything let's see there's anything in
here that looks like it might mess
things up no nothing there just
double-check yeah if we took out
everything we needed there okay
okay so if we switch from using having
it say max with 25% and instead have
with 25% then that works a lot better
mmm
so I guess now the question is is it
worth it to go in and switch these
classes up or should we bring in our own
system so much time we have before we
tackle at eight minutes let's we don't
really have to change anything in here
we just need to add with
oh okay John Hansen I just saw your
comment about the image with that makes
sense so notice this was only happening
on images so let's take this back to max
with so the text was fine the events are
the events are okay they do look
different than they did before but this
actually isn't yeah let's see if we can
do this so we want the interior of not
of that one this one
hmm the card width is set to a hundred
percent interesting let's see
all right so we're actually not getting
hmm yeah Joanne you caught that they're
using a CSS background image yeah so
that's kind of not that's not obvious
from the way it looks in the code right
let's show where the code is yeah so you
have this card media and you put an
image and Atari right it looks like this
should convert it to an image tag but
it's not it's a background image so I
mean that's fine there's nothing wrong
with that
but it is gonna make we just have to
make a decision really about what we're
gonna do with these with these cards how
we're gonna handle this this issue here
I guess we could make
John Hanson says you need to have the
elements in each flex div stretch
all right so what's the as it flex I'm
not good enough with flexbox to know
what the command is where you put
stretch on flex start
so is it flex flex basis flex direction
I can look it up but I figured John if
you knew offhand it might be faster
yeah definitely not not basis I just saw
it somewhere where did I have it at I
was just thinking I just saw it in the
documentation for material you I it was
in the it was in the API for grid I
think
no not grid list
do they not have an API grid align items
okay we're justify content yep that's it
that's what I just I just remember I saw
it there
you had it first that John thank you all
right let's see flex yeah let's go
million item stretch all right not that
one
let's try I might be putting it on the
wrong thing - one time stretch let's try
putting it on a different or something
here
nope hi this one
nope
okay alright so that's not working hi
there I'm I may be doing it wrong but I
think now we're back to we're not going
to be able to use grid unless we make
our own classes
let's see you need to see what direction
first row or column
hmm let's see
or what we have now that's for index e
we don't have a container anymore that's
setting it if we did it it was said it
column don't know if we have our overall
container still as is using flex
yeah all right well my timer is up so I
guess I'll work on this work on this for
a little bit today maybe or tomorrow
morning
and so maybe before tomorrow a stream
I'll have I'll have this working I'm not
sure what the best solution will be at
this point but I'll either create some
of my own classes to handle the width
issue or and continue using it with the
the grid elements or I will just import
the column classes from materialize and
bring them in and use them just like we
did in that bulletin project if we do it
just like the bulletin project that does
have the benefit of being able to just
really reuse you know code between the
two projects which is nice
I'm also way more familiar with
materialized column classes than I am
with the material you eye classes for
grid and all the options they have so
we'll see it'll be one of those - all
right so let me scroll up now to where I
left off in the live chat and I'm gonna
go through an answer everything that's
in the live chat now if you have a
question please put it in the chat now
when I get through everything that'll be
the end of the stream
let's see kou-kun and Angie says Sweden
says hello hello Sweden thanks for
watching
novena why can't we use polymer for
material designs you can use polymer in
a lot of cases I'm not sure where we're
at as far as being able to use polymer
components in react
I'm sure it's either been done or
there's somebody working on it some sort
of you know library to be able to use
that but I just haven't tried it so I I
mean I'd be open to trying it probably
not on this project because we you know
we have a tight deadline so I don't want
to have to learn something new if I can
help it for this project but maybe for a
future project we'll have to find it I
said I'm not aware exactly if of anybody
doing that right now but I'm sure
somebody is doing it
ah hey sin sins s YNS says hey how do
you make your github look like that yes
so I'm using the dark theme for github
so you have to download tampermonkey if
you're on Chrome
I believe Firefox has an equivalent I
don't know if it's called tampermonkey
or something else and then you need to
get the github dark script so if you
type in github dark it should come up in
the search and it'll have directions for
how to make that work then you get this
theme and you also get more options so
you get all these github dark settings
to change things and you know I have
this theme on but there's lots of
different themes that I could be using
so anyway it's pretty cool I always like
the dark themes better I think it's
easier on the eyes but that's how I get
my github it look like that
journeys
wait ah all right so w ey ir a waiver
way uh sorry I want to pronounce that
right so let me know I'm probably
pronouncing it wrong let me know how it
should be pronounced and I'll do my best
to remember and pronounce it right
but anyway they say I joined today and
would love to do all five projects how
do I find it okay
I don't I have every project in its own
playlist yet some of them have their own
playlist but the live coding with Jessie
playlist on this channel the free code
camp channel on YouTube has all the
projects in order if you go back to the
first video that's project one and you
go through right now the titles will
tell you what project it is I think for
project one I don't actually say it's
project one but for all the projects
after that I have it right in the title
so it'll say like P two and then D like
five for your like project to day five
so right now that's like the one big
playlist as everything I'm going to
continue to break things out as well in
the separate playlist to make it easier
to follow along and I'm glad you join
welcome
I'm I'm mission says how long did it
take you to learn graph QL I I don't
know I mean I kind of I learned it on
the stream with you also
I've only been streaming for like eight
months something like that maybe nine
months so less than nine months for sure
and probably way less than nine months
so I don't I don't know graph QL like
I'm no expert at graph QL I know enough
to definitely use graph QL you know in
terms of from the client side of getting
things from graph QL in terms of setting
things up servers
I'm I don't really know that much about
it so I haven't created my own graphic
you of API from scratch or anything yet
I imagine probably end up doing it at
some point but to be able to learn how
to get data from a graph QL API that's
that's pretty easy especially if you
already understand how API is work like
a REST API it's not really that hard to
make a jump to graph QL and if you're
using some sort of helper library like
if you're using Apollo you know it makes
it really easy so if you want to get
into graph QL I'd say like client side
it shouldn't take too long at all
server side I don't really know because
I haven't gotten into that yet guru Tegh
says why don't you try material design
bootstrap you know what actually I I
haven't checked on that in quite a while
to see if that was good I remember you
know several years ago when I was trying
to decide on a material design
you know framework to use I didn't like
it as much as materialize I don't know
where that projects at now although
maybe it's better now I just don't know
let's see Robert asks is it better to
use materializer bootstrap I I don't I
think it depends on what kind of look
you want if you're trying to go for a
material design look you're gonna it's
going to be easier for you to use
materialize you could certainly use
bootstrap and then just adjust it you
know I I wouldn't adjust it directly but
I maybe like add you know a theme on the
of your own on to use in addition to
bootstrap then you could make it look
like the tier design - but why you know
I don't really see the point in spending
all that time trying to turn bootstrap
into something else
so it just depends on the look if I
didn't want a material design look if I
didn't if it didn't matter whether or
not I had a material design look maybe
I'd go to bootstrap because more people
use it so the odds of you know the
testing is better right there's just way
more people using it reporting errors
and things like that more people working
on it it would take me a little while to
get used to the bootstrap way of doing
things because I have much more
experience with materialised I have
build things with bootstrap before but
you know with materialised I remember a
lot of the classes without having to
look them up with bootstrap I don't so
for me I would probably go with
materialise just because of that but if
I was starting from scratch
I'd go with if you want material design
use materialized otherwise build a
bootstrap that'd be my recommendation
kaathal says only came in now what is
masonry used for so the masonry the
concept of a masonry grid is I mean it's
pretty basically just this isn't a good
example and it's all messed up now but
basically you just have all these
different you know elements with
different shapes different sizes right
different widths and Heights and they
all fit together with the same amount of
space in between with the same gutter
and as you change the window width they
all adjust so that you don't have this
weird space in between that's what I
mean when I'm talking about masonry and
so we actually use this masonry
component there it is react masonry
component and what this does is it takes
the masonry package that was made for up
by I think it's like dis saundra or
something like that trying to make one
of the other thing so masonry use the
free version
there's another package JavaScript
plug-in called isotope this is a paid
version and it basically handles this
masonry layout some sorting and things
like that but it's just a regular you
know JavaScript plug-in this is a
component that takes that and you know
it actually uses that code but it makes
it into a react component so it makes it
a lot easier to use with with react so
that's how we're using you know masonry
in our project and this is the best
masonry layout library this one here
that I've seen I wonder if there's a
link I'm actually surprised that there's
not a link to the original the original
site
hmm if you look up masonry or isotope as
you know like a JavaScript plug-in you
should find it and you'll see more demos
and it kind of like what it could do
here we go there's a link to dis Andros
page so here it is this is the masonry
grid layout so you can use it with
jQuery without jQuery and the regular
version but then if you want to use it
with materialise I recommend using the
the component that that we were just
looking at just makes it a whole lot
easier I believe we tried to do it with
this on one project and it wasn't
impossible to do but it was definitely
more difficult
I look says anyone here heard of em you
URI Murray grid system does say miss
thing as masonry only saw a live demo
I've never heard of it I've never used
it so I might be cool to check out you
know see if it's if it's better than
masonry I mean it seems like masonry is
kept up to date I mean there's some
updates from five days ago that's pretty
cool yeah so maybe it's kept up to date
but has been around for quite a while
there might be something new or out
there that does a better job maybe more
lightweight
Edwin says you robbed bro thanks for the
for constant the constant motivation
you're welcome I'm glad I can give you
some some motivation here I actually had
trouble getting motivated coming back
from the holiday break there I thought
about making a video about how I ended
up getting myself motivated to help out
so we'll see maybe I'll make one
but this stream always motivates me so
if I can help motivate you all I'm
really happy about that
then a yak says background size cover or
100% for the image maybe yeah let's try
that out
where's our here
backgrounds cover about mmm nope
good suggestion though
Oh sin says they see the dark theme for
github with stylish not same alright
let's check out that dark theme then
let's see I think this is what I use
yeah this is this is what I use
yeah so basically what you want to do is
I think I used the userscript add-on
it's yeah so I did the chrome install
with tampermonkey so evidently there's a
lot of different ways to use this so I
already had tampermonkey installed
that's why I did it this way if you
don't have tampermonkey installed it
looks like you can get you can get
add-ons you know for other things so one
of these ways should work the way I use
was to add the script directly into
tampermonkey beyond ad IO and any I'm
pretty sure it's Dion right I think we
may have talked about this before
correct me if it's not if it's not
pronounced that way
Dion says bootstrap is more flexible
materialized as more rigid to custom
changes I definitely agree that's
actually that's a really good answer so
we were talking about whether or not to
use materialized bootstrap that's a
really good point bootstrap is more like
designed neutral and meant to be changed
but you realize it has a purpose of
being material design style so it's it
definitely is not as open to being
adjusted so yeah I definitely agree so
that's if you want material design go
with it but if you don't care about
material design bootstrap is definitely
the way to go
you'll have an easier time of creating
your own style thanks for that deal and
that was a really good point
ketosis thanks for the thorough
explanation on masonry you're welcome I
hope that was helping for you let's see
ok sin says yeah I use it with stylish
and that works but it's not the same as
yours that's interesting I wonder why
it's possible mine's different because I
have an older version I am an older
version that's not been updated awhile
co2 4 - oops
oh yeah I think I may be pretty behind
in terms of versions whoops
where'd I find that 120 I don't know
actually is this the CSS version you
know I'm not that far behind
that's weird does it auto-update then
anyway I have no idea why mine looks
different okay since ed I installed the
tampermonkey one and it seems way better
than the others okay cool I had never
tried any other ones so I just lucked
out then and got the good one right off
the bat okay and it is the same cool
yeah I did tell you truth I didn't even
realize there were other ways to use it
it's I sold it a while ago and I haven't
looked at the documentation since then I
haven't really tried out any options it
might be cool to you mess with those at
some point all right so I've got through
the live chat and Wow my slack for work
has a lot of messages and so does my
email so now is a great time to wrap
things up and see what's going on before
I before I head out I actually have to
leave work early because my car won't
start so cold my car won't start
so my wife's car is a lot newer and it
is starting up so she has to pick me up
from work and so she needs to pick me up
earlier than normal so I need to quit
talking and get ready and leave but
thank you all so much for watching and
for helping out in the live chat and
thanks for all the questions I love it
when there's a lot of questions gives me
something to talk about and it's cool I
like whenever we can help each other out
I should be back tomorrow's Taurus
Friday already Wow
this week went so fast so anyway I
should be back tomorrow around the same
time I'm gonna try to do the streams
closer to one o'clock now I used to
always aim for two o'clock but I really
want to do it earlier for everybody over
and
and in that area in that time zone
because you know I don't want to keep
you all up really late and I know
there's a lot of viewers from that from
that area of the world so plan on being
around 1:00 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
I'll do my best to to keep it around
that time and hopefully tomorrow I have
some of this sorted out some of this
masonry stuff sorted out and we'll have
something a little bit nicer to look at
but until then thanks again and have a
great day